ياكلون العقارب ويشربون دماء الافاعي هذه
ليست طرق تعذيب في احد السجون المرعبه او
طقوسا طائفه ما وانما تدريبات لبعض الجيوش
حول العالم قوه المارينز الامريكيه تسافر
الى تايلاند خصوصا للمشاركه في مناورات
الكبرى الذهبيه باجراء تدريبات القدره على
نجاه التي تتضمن قتل الدجاج بالايدي واكل
العقارب والعناكب وهي حيه اضافه الى
اصطياد افاعي الكبرى وشرب دمائها في الصين
وكوريا الجنوبيه يرجى الجيشان تدريبات
فريده من نوعها تتضمن قيام الجنود بكسر
الطوب والواح الخشب باستخدام ايديهم
ومن الصين الى تايوان حيث يقوم الجيش
التايواني بالزحف على طريق مليء بالصخور
الخشنه والشعاب المرجانيه
اما في بيلاروسيا فيتعين على الجيوش
اجتياز اختبار يحاكي التعرض الى هجوم
بالاسلحه الكيماويه